SOUTH KOREA NEXT MONTH.
IF YOU WERE IN THE U.S.
ILLEGALLY, WOULD YOU SAY SO ON A
CENSUS FORM?
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF INTENSE
AND EMOTIONAL DEBATE TONIGHT
AFTER THE COMMERCE DEPARTMENT
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT A CITIZENSHIP
QUESTION WILL BE ON THE 2020
CENSUS.
CORRESPONDENT DOUG McKELWAY
LOOKS AT WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION DELIVER
THE NEWS QUIETLY BE A PRESS
RELEASE LAST NIGHT AT 9:29 P.M.
AFTER WEEKS OF BUILDING
CONTROVERSY.
"TODAY THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE ANNOUNCED A QUESTION ON
CITIZENSHIP STATUS WILL BE
REINSTATED TO THE 2020 CENSUS."
IMMIGRATION GROUPS REACTED WITH
EXPECTED OUTRAGE.
CALIFORNIA'S ATTORNEY GENERAL
PRIMITIVELY FILED SUIT.
SUPPORTERS NOTED THAT THE
QUESTION HAVE BEEN INCLUDED IN
CENSUSES UNTIL 1950.
>> THERE'S NO PROOF HE PREVENTED
ANYONE --
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA XAVIER BECERRA HAS
SUED SAYING IT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
>> IN THE LETTER REQUESTING THE
CHANGE IN DECEMBER, DOJ NOTED
CITIZENSHIP DATA IS CRITICAL TO
IMPORTANT PRODUCTIONS.
IMMIGRATION RIGHTS GROUPS
REJECTED IT.
>> WE SEE THIS AS AN
INTIMIDATION DESIGNED TO
FRIGHTEN IMMIGRANTS FROM NOT
PARTICIPATING IN THE SENSES.
>> PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS
DENIED THE CHANGE CAME FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE SUPPORTS IT
BUT THE DECISION WAS MADE BY THE
DEPARTMENT.
>> BOTH SIDES AGREE NOT
PARTICIPATING IN THE CENSUS
SKUs DATA WHICH HELPS
DETERMINE THE ALLOCATION OF
GOVERNMENT RESOURCES.
>> HOW THE DISTRICTS ARE DRAWN
HAS ENORMOUS APPLICATIONS FOR
HOW MUCH POLITICAL
REPRESENTATION YOU HAVE.
THE CHANCE OF YOUR CANDIDATE
WINNING.
>> IN 2010, CENSUS TAKERS
DOCUMENTED A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN LEGAL AND ILLEGAL
NONCITIZENS.
THE STATE GAINED FIVE
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS.
THERE ARE DOUBTS WHETHER A
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION WOULD
SUBSTANTIALLY DETER IMMIGRANTS
FROM PARTICIPATING IN THE
CENSUS.
>> WE ASK IT ON THE SERIES OF
OTHER CENSUS QUESTIONS.
NOT ONLY CITIZENSHIP BUT A WHOLE
DETAILED SET OF RELATED
QUESTIONS.
>> 2.1% OF RESPONDENTS FAILED TO
SHARE CITIZENSHIP DATA.
NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC
SCHNEIDERMAN SAID HE WILL JOIN
CALIFORNIA'S ATTORNEY GENERAL
LEADING A MULTISTATE LAWSUIT
SHOULD PRESERVE WHAT HE CALLS A